what about the happiness you said that
that's one of the problems of when
you're out in space how do you keep
humans happy again asking for a friend
yes i mean one of the big challenges is
you can't just open a window or walk out
a door and blow off steam right you
can't just
go somewhere to clear your head
and in that sense you need to build
habitats that are homes that really care
for the humans inside them and have
whether it's biophilia and a place where
you can go and feel like you're in
nature or a vr headset which for some
people is a
a poor simulchrum but is maybe better
than nothing um you need to be thinking
about these technological interventions
that are going to have to be part of
your home and be part of your maybe
day-to-day ritual to keep you steady and
balanced and happy or feeling fulfilled
what about other humans relationship
with other humans do those get
those get weird when you get past a
certain number of humans i'm not an
expert in this area but an anecdote that
i'll share my uh understanding is that
nasa has still not decided whether it's
better to send married couples or single
crew members in terms of uh you want
some level of stability you don't want
to have the drama of romantic
relationships like you're you know
alluding to before but they can't decide
because married couples also fight yeah
and have a really tough dynamic and so
there's a lot of open questions still to
answer about what is the ideal
psychological makeup of a crew and we're
starting to test some of these things
with the civilian crews that are going
up with inspiration four like last fall
with spacex and acts one that's gonna
fly in a few days here in march
as we begin to lengthen the
time of those civilian crews i think
we'll start to learn a little bit more
about just average everyday human to
human dynamics and not the astronauts
that are themselves selected to be
perfect human specimens very good to
work with easy to get along with i wish
you collected more data about this
pandemic because i feel like it's a good
rough simulation of what would be out in
space a lot of people were locked down
some married couples i think a lot of
marriages broke up a lot of marriages
got closer together
um so it's like
and then the the single people some of
them went off
the cliff and some of them discovered
their new happiness and meaning and so
on it's a beautiful little experiment a
painful one yeah is there a thorough way
to really test that
to
because it's such a costly experiment
to send humans up there but i guess you
can always return back to earth if it's
not working out that's what we hope
you hope you don't have like a you know
apollo 13 situation that doesn't quite
make it back but yeah the
this is also why mars is such a
challenge the moon is only three days
away that's a lot quicker to recover
from if there's a psychological problem
with the crew or any type of maintenance
problem anything
three years is
such a
challenge compared to these other
domains that we've been getting more
used to in terms of human space flight
so this is a question that we will need
to have explored more before we start
really sending crews to mars
you